e les shérifs a parlé de l'iceberg la
spa parce que demain je vous le dis je
suis en mesure de vous dire on aura le
ministre de l'agriculture avec nous et
le président de la spa on a réussi on a
réussi à les réunir demain et vous savez
que les choses ont bougé puisqu'à partir
de jeudi 16 avril une tolérance sera
accordée dans les débats dans les
déplacements
malgré le confinement pour les personnes
souhaitant adopter un animal refuge
ça c'est une nouvelle exceptionnelle des
règles strictes devront toutefois être
respecter l'animal devrait être choisi
en amont un rendez vous précis sera fixé
et le refuge concernés et mettra une
attestation dématérialisée comportant
l'horaire du rendez vous
le candidat l'adoption devra se déplacer
seul et être muni en plus de
l'attestation délivrée par le refuge
d'une attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire pour motif familial
impérieux pour rappel la sp a avait
réclamé au gouvernement une dérogation
pour que les gens puissent venir adopter
les pensionnaires de ses 62 refuge
bientôt saturé et donc ça y est c'est
fait c'est magnifique je vous dis je
sais pas si on a jean charles
aujourd'hui jean charles fombonne le
président de la svm il sera avec nous
demain quoi qu'il arrive avec le
ministre de l'agriculture est vraiment
je ne sais pas si on a fait bouger les
choses mais je vous le dis je suis
extrêmement heureux de ce qui se passe
puisque vous allez pouvoir allait
adopter des animaux et ça c'est une
nouvelle exceptionnelle oui et jean
michel baylet il syrie et surtout qu' on
pourrait dire que c'est un peu futiles
comme nouvelle ce n'est pas une nouvelle
du touch est il que sans cette avancée
vous avez contribué à faire des milliers
et des milliers de chiens et chats web
l'euthanasie pour et eddy chevaillier
dans les miens surviennent son ca reste
donc ces provinces titre ont postés oui
gilles verdez bien sûr que c'est la
mobilisation dont la vo dont ce que vous
avez dit qui a permis d'avancer
à noter que c'est le ministère de
l'agriculture est aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner qui sont
saisis du dossier
parce qu'une dérogation ça s'accorde pas
facilement c'est parce que cette
mobilisation tout à fait légitime que ça
a évolué vous savez en france quand on
se mobilise ça fait avancer les choses
voilà ce qui s'est passé non mais là je
suis tellement heureux vous pouvez pas
savoir donc voilà pour tous nos animaux
vous allez pouvoir allait adopter des
animaux s'est offert une personne de
plus dans votre famille peut-être en
cette période de confinement sellin
dites pas que je sais que c'est très
important pour tous les catholiques
voilà c'était pesaro si cette journée
c'est le ramadhan le 24 avril et c'est
vrai que les trois fait comme ça voilà
bon bien sûr on est tous confinés et
j'espère que ça va nous permettre aussi
des cerveaux permettre de faire les
fêtes en famille
êtes vous retrouvé c'est extrêmement
important aussi et je le dis c'est
extrêmement important pour moi voilà que
de savoir que toutes les familles se
réunissent je vois plein de messages sur
twitter de gens qui nous disent oui le
confinement c'est dur mais ça m'a permis
de passer plus de temps avec mes enfants
de savoir dans connaître encore un peu
plus sur mes enfants de les connaître
mieux de savoir comme ils vivent d
essayer de les faire travailler de fait
partager plein de choses avec eux et ça
je vous dire bien sûr c'est une
catastrophe qu'on vit en ce moment mais
tout ça mine de rien je trouve que c'est
une excellente nouvelle et j'espère que
je pense que les familles ne vont plus
jamais comme avant
après ce confinement parce que forcément
c'est vrai qu'elles vont connaître des
choses qu'elles n'ont pas connu avant et
voilà je vous le dis j'espère que vous
aller voilà vous avez passé un bon lundi
de pâques en tout cas on va tout faire
pour